[Musique]
c'est vous le journaliste et c'est
reparti pour une nouvelle saison
télévisuelle une saison presque normal
malgré la pandémie qui complexifie les
tournages
la première des choses c'est que tout le
monde a tourné à tout le monde a pu
réaliser ce qu'ils avaient a réalisé il
ya des des exploits j'ose dire exploit
parce que tout le monde a trouvé les
solutions france beaudoin sera de retour
à la barre dans direct de l'univers au
chapitre des nouveautés ni blanche une
saga familiale mettant en vedette france
castel et rose marie thé
les téléspectateurs pourront aussi
découvrir après une série mettant en
vedette karine vanasse et qui raconte
une histoire du courage et de résilience
dans une petite communauté des
laurentides
parmi les retours attendus roy dupuis
reprend son rôle de christophe l'allier
mais les nouvelles responsable
pédagogique fera son entrée à l'école
marie la drake pour le meilleur ou pour
le pire des beaux-parents s'ajoutent à
la distribution des discussions avec les
parents
alors que la mort rôdera dès les
premiers épisodes des districts 31 tout
ce que je peux dire en fait c'est que
j'espère que les gens vont être
confortablement assis à leurs chères
alors fauteuil parce que ça va déménager
sa part sur les chapeaux de roue
canada poursuit son virage jeunesse avec
des finitions comme alex et les
merveilleux l'agent jean houle effets
secondaires en plus du 23 nouveautés qui
sont ajoutés à la grille dont défense
d'entrée la série inspirée des livres de
caroline héroux allez vous vous
présentez condamner les plantes on va
changer municipal lui a lepage est de
retour à la barre de tout le monde en
parle anaïs favron alexandre barrette
alterneront avec des coins animateurs de
soir dans le rôle du fou du roi fo man
ne manqueront pas de sujet avec les
campagnes électorales en cours et les
suites de la pandémie l'an dernier radio
canada a connu une amie record ce qui
est arrivé avec la pandémie c'est que
les gens s'en retourner vers des valeurs
sûres et en trouver à leur compte et on
dirait qu'ils ont re découvert le
bien-être chez soi d'écouté des belles
initiant une rentrée télé variés qui
promet d'être captivante ici n'est bien
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal